facts about it in the sixteenth season
of the on the Discovery Channel and has
shown not shown any signs of slowing
down just yet Jacy sat down with Richard
Rawlings the mastermind behind gas
monkey garage I am a huge fan of fast
and loud first things first though
Richard Rawlings last time I saw you
would in Monday night and you were
jumping out of an airplane how are we
doing today I love that stuff I've
actually done it quite a few times I'd
like to go get my license and be able to
do without another dude strapped onto my
back but it was a good time
well the video was awesome what else is
awesome something you're doing down
there in Texas that you did actually
with your gas monkey energy drink
helping out so many people during this
during this pandemic why don't you
explain what you did and and why he did
it I was a police officer a firefighter
earlier why so the frontlines is really
you know near and dear to my heart
and I was like you know I'd like to help
the first responders the EMS the
firefighters police the hospital
districts and I just said well how much
energy drinks do we have in there and we
had a lot we had I think 16 truckloads
and we were teamed up with Barnhardt
trucking and we were able to distribute
all 16 18 wheelers in 10 days all over
the nation straight to the front line
couple questions about the current
season he kind of started things off the
season with that with that build for a
Gary Sinise that Jeep built it was so
cool for the cherami you guys were doing
is there a certain celebrity over the
years and the seasons that jumped out
too that was just awesome to work with
or maybe got nervous around the circus
Liberty well nothing you just mentioning
but I mean Gary Sinise says so much for
our wounded veterans that you know he
was a joy work with it and just an
awesome individual all the way around
you know and I've had the opportunity to
work with the likes of Chip Foose you
know as far as I'm concerned one of the
best car builders in the world and but
my favorite you know Burt Reynolds you
know getting to work with Burt Reynolds
about six or so years ago and go to his
house and hang out and see his
memorabilia and you know just everything
there was Burt Reynolds it was like holy
cow I've died and gone to Burt real
savage on this season you've had the
Datsun 280z too but an awesome build you
guys did and then you sold the car
this season than we saw and why don't
you tell everybody what happened after
you sold the vehicle because this blows
my mind it burned to the ground the
trailer that it was riding in had a
Ferrari at a couple of bittley's in
there too you know I mean there's just
some high-dollar cars and they called me
up and they said it burned to the ground
I said what happy no way show me a
picture trailer everything was soft does
your heart just break when that happens
to one your projects yeah and then
luckily it hasn't happened that many
times we wrecked the Mustang early in
season one and this car burned to the
ground and we reckon so three out of a
hundred and seventy or so cars is is not
bad my final question how much cash do
you have money right now didn't always
seem thinking wrong with wads of money
how much cash you got let's see it looks
a little light today I'd say this is
about seven or eight I'm trying to
virtually grab it if you want to give it
to my content virtually ah thank you I'm
ready to bring it to Vegas y'all need to
open up there I've got my I haven't had
a gamblin fixing quite some time and I
usually get out the Vegas six to ten
times a year so I gotta get out there